[Music]
we might have talked about this before
but we definitely Marcus has this
hilarious idea
for a sketch that he wants to pitch
Friday beers but it's like a magician
getting pulled up like a drunk magician
getting pulled over by the cops a drunk
guy exactly
and he like handsome is like licensed
and I was like it's a [__] Dove or
something like that what the [__] the
[__] I'm just kidding his back then
you're like he's like you know what you
like get up you know get out of the car
whatever he puts him in cuffs and the
cop like turns around then he's in cuffs
and he's like what the [__] and the The
Magician's out of them
start sawing him in half and that's the
part where he's not drunk and he [__]
it up cops like
he's like oh [__] whoops
opens his wallet and it's just like one
giant ribbon
oh just hold on a license in there
somewhere hold on I gotta get rid of
this sir maybe it's in the old prison
wallet oh look at that
his ass
he wants to see a cool trick
these sisters go to the monologue you
know they say we're all connected
you know behind one hole is another
let's say I took my registration here
and I put it back in my ass
no no no where's my license why don't
you check up your ass he puts it he puts
his license in his ass
and he's like
oh if I just if I just
cops like oh
that's amazing holy [__] how did you get
that in my ass
you never heard David Blaine should read
throws the cards at the window to the
other side of the window
he's like he's step size does a sobriety
thing it's like I don't need utilize
registration he's like all right you
want my license
let me show you listen
you ever play a 52 card pickup then
that's all I'm getting somewhere
taste the cars throws them at his car
window and his license registration is
perfectly on the other side
he's like what do you think about that
Kyle's like that's amazing
cop opens the door goes to grab it the
guy pushes him in the car lights the car
on fire yeah
foreign
Jesus Christ the car drives away drunk
in a car a magician never reveals
this drink that he drives off a bridge
[Music]
[Laughter]
just drowns in there
damn what is this dude this is just
Friday night right here now if I'm
dressed like that put me in a hole
in a living room oh [__] man I showed
the Friday beers guys the the whole
video yeah yeah they could not believe
it oh man that's going crazy that is a
classic oh it's so good man yeah dude
House of gourd gotta love it you know I
was looking into two girls one cup
how's that going it's so what did you
find out so it was actually a trailer
for a scat film called hungry [__] oh
yeah yeah don't go watch it so that
rumor that the poop was fake
came from because he got um
he had to go to court because the film
was so was he uh the director okay the
film was so vile
they had to show up in court for some
reason and he
unsuccessfully argued that the poop was
fake so I think that poop was real wow
no way and it's like a full-on you know
just scat film so did he get like
charged with anything uh I don't no
but it you know it's kind of crazy man
that movie has such like the scene
produced from that
oh jailed jailed jailed wait what is
this Isaac's trial focus on the
bestiality heavy Japanese doggy
three-way and several other full-length
scat-heavy movies like Hollywood scat
amateurs number six yeah man locked this
guy up lock this guy number seven I'm
not sorry lock this guy up dude this guy
is insane man
if this is King shaming I don't care oh
this is funny Isaacs had previously
cited two girls one cup as inspiration
that poop porn could become widely
popular hey he did that though I know he
did that oh my god dude
this [__] kid at the airport just now
comes up to me and goes excuse me are
you him
and I went yeah I am him
who's him though like he just got
nervous uh so he just said are you him I
just thought it was really funny yeah
I'm him
okay and he takes a picture of me and
leaves never says my name nothing I'm
him what can I say I'm him anyway sorry
go back until I saw two girls one cup I
wouldn't have thought so many regular
people would want to watch this stuff he
told radar in 2008 there are millions of
people watching it yep
well that's so funny it's like
I don't know that perspective is sort of
like you know it's a Adam jockle yeah
like people are really [__] with my
model shots you know like people love
this [__] you know it's a Pavlov if you
start playing that piano from the two
girls one cup video
what is that it's like a soft it's the
eeriest piece like dude but it's kind of
crazy because
like I was I was reading the Wikipedia
but it makes such a good point
that that was the first really big piece
of reaction content that's all YouTube
was probably like a period it was just
friends reacting to yeah girls one cup
yeah so true
oh you [__] ew
[Music]
dude oh my God oh my God
I know dude we need some ear bleach put
on a perverse family
it's just someone vomiting yeah yeah
okay thank god oh man dude that piano
bro gives me the creeps oh stop
this this corner the bottom bottom line
is the artist determines their art
Isaac's told adult industry news service
X Biz him sitting down with X Biz in a
[__] like porn room with a couch and
being like the artist determines the art
I did not think as so many people would
be so enamored with my [__] and poop so
I decided to
make more movies with this is he a
talent no that was good what he is
I
he's an artist that's what he is yeah
he's a [__] artist
yeah bro I I was uh I was just kind of
wigging out on the cultural significance
of two girls one cup
also what an American what is
we did what uh
like when movies go overseas yeah we did
what they do what do you mean it's like
you know if it's like a fast and furious
movie it's like action and fast cars
like they always retitle the movie
something really literal oh to sell it
yeah I see because if the brand is not
like if people don't recognize Fast and
Furious doesn't like translate yeah yeah
yeah so they have to like do something
that gets people to go to the theater so
we did that the Vin Diesel yeah
Vin Diesel six yeah Vin Diesel drives
again six oh it's the one with the guns
on the cars two Vin two diesel yeah
and then that clip just went around as
two girls one cup yeah
then we had that whole Arrow one guy one
jar
oh yeah it [__] that guy is an artist
I mean he would he [__] went to jail
for yeah I mean all good artists go to
jail man that's what they say man I mean
that's why milk went to jail you know
yeah exactly
it really is wild though that what that
[__] inspired yeah